cake boss buddy valastro continues to
bring his new jersey flare to the las
vegas strip he's set to open his fourth
restaurant and jillian went to catch up
with the baker
[Music]
hey so we're inside buddy bees at the
venetian talking about a lot of exciting
things happening this year and i'm with
the man himself hi buddy how are you how
you doing jillian good to see you again
you too thanks for having us here and
you know you've been deemed the cake
boss but i'm going to call you the las
vegas boss because you're taking over
the shrimp
let's talk about what you have planned
this year well i'm going to tell you
vegas is like a second home to me and i
feel like it's really the culinary
capital of the world
right i mean there's not a two mile
stretch where you have more
wonderful restaurants on the planet than
in las vegas so naturally anytime i want
to do something i want to do it in vegas
right and for me i think the uniqueness
is that you have
so many different restaurants from
all over the world and all different
flavors and flares so it's like i want
to bring my jersey flare
to las vegas and we're happy to have it
yeah
so you know again we got buddy bees
which is here at the venetian eight
years knock on wood going strong
congratulations it is basically i want
you to come to bodybees and feel like
you're eating
dinner at my house uh it's a sloppy red
sauce place right it's jersey it's good
food it's from the heart you know you
feel like my grandma rolled the
meatballs and
my wife made the eggplant farm uh so
that that's kind of what buddy vs is in
nutshell and then of course we have the
iconic carlos bakery which i'm kind of
famous for with everything and that's
right here in the venetian as well talk
about the new plays and what people can
expect there okay so the new concept is
called the boss cafe and it's gonna be
at the link and basically what i'm doing
there is
there's three main components
one we're doing bakery style pizza
so it's very different than what we
would do a pizza cake because that's
like a new york style slice
we're doing
sandwiches so we're taking the same
bakery pizza without the sauce we're
cutting it in half we're making
sandwiches what kind of sandwiches it's
all about the months baby you know what
the foods is the fresh meats all right
so the fresh muts is is
something that we have in every
jersey deli or new york deli fresh
mozzarella made by hand you're gonna see
it happening okay it's creamy it's
dreamy when you put that with like roast
beef
and
um some hot and cherry peppers in there
dipped in a little jew
i mean it melts in your mouth it's
creamy it's creamy you haven't lived
until you had
a sandwich like a roast beef and mutts
jersey style that sounds like a dream
come true that's all you need buddy
congratulations thank you for bringing
your talent here to vegas and i think
we're just going to keep rolling it out
there's more to come right you know it